in belgium at least six people have been
killed in several dozens injured after a
car drove at high speed into a crowd
people had gathered for early morning
carnival celebrations in streppy brachie
a small town south of brussels media
reports said the crash may have been
caused as the vehicle was being chased
by police
brussels correspondent marina strauss
joins us now marina what more do you
know
there's a press conference ongoing at
this point of time so we're learning
we're still learning what happened there
what caused this tragic catastrophe here
in belgium a bit south of brussels in a
very small town we know that six people
at least six people have died that 10
are seriously injured and have been
brought to a hospital at that 27 more
are also injured and are in some danger
so the the mayor of this uh small town
just spoke and said that um this morning
at five o'clock about
150 to 200 people gathered
and they traditionally celebrate
carnival from the early morning though
they go from house to house together and
then have this traditional carnival
celebration
and then a car crashed into this group
of people it's not clear yet how it
happened it's still being investigated
but of course we have condolences coming
in for example from the belgium prime
minister who will also travel there um
this afternoon at four o'clock and he
said that this is horrible news he just
got also the interior minister of
belgium said that and this is a horrible
incident and a catastrophe for belgium
and that her thoughts are with the
families of those who have died
did the may say anything about the
reasons why the car drove into the
crowd at the press conference the mayor
spoke and then a doctor spoke and he
gave some indications on the two um
people who caused this incident
apparently was two people in a car
two men one born in 89 one born in 90s
so about 30 years old and they're both
from the region
and
there are
other mobile experts now on the case
and the two persons that have been taken
in by the police will now be questioned
but no further information has been
given at this point
marina strauss for us in brussels thanks
for the update
you